hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild tactical frenzy of a game you guys
requested also from the world rapid Team
Championship it is Indian Grandmaster
chitambara maravin versus a former World
classical Champion vishwanathan Anand
it's a quite a brutal game you guys will
enjoy it uh many many variations for a
rapid game uh so let's dive straight
into it and it features a very uh
tactical opening that is the Queen's
Gambit accepted so let's check it out
chitambaram has the white pieces and he
opens with the D4 we have Pawn to D5 C4
and now D captures on C4 Anand accepts
the Queen's Gambit which means that it's
going to be a very wild game and here we
have Pawn to E4 uh for I would just like
to mention for those of you who are
maybe just starting out your chess
Journey one of the nicer lines that I've
learned a long long time ago when I
started learning chess was uh that uh
well the the standard was to meet this D
captures on C4 with Ponte E3 and now
black will defend the pawn here you will
undermine the pawn black will defend the
pawn and now you you just capture on B5
and you are already very very close to
winning especially if your opponent
doesn't really uh you know isn't really
careful of what he's doing he might
capture and then you will play Queen to
F3 and win the game on the spot of
course you don't win the Rogue but black
will have to give up the Knight and then
when you capture the Knight okay then
you move the queen and you continue just
being up a piece but here E4 is the most
uh concrete attempt and now we have Pawn
to B5 now the the exact same line can be
played as the E4 Pawn prevents Queen to
F3 at the end of the line so A4 we have
Pawn to C6 captures captures now okay
this is impossible uh and now Knight the
C3 by chitambaram we have Queen to B6 by
Anand and now two moves that are almost
exclusively played here are Knights the
D5 to attack the queen and pawn to B3 to
challenge Black's Pawn structure on the
queen side but here we have Queen to H5
it's not a new move it has only been
played once before and uh why why would
you do this why would you bring your
queen out like this so early in the game
game well uh the the idea is that if
Queen captures on D4 which is a really
crazy line uh White uh just gets a whole
lot of Advantage Knight captures on B5
attacks the queen and also threatens
Knight to C7 check so you capture the E4
Pawn as well and now after Bishop to E2
you defend with Queen to B7 now comes
Bishop to F3 attacks the queen here and
you will play Knight to C6 then comes
Bishop to F4 of course you still want to
deliver Knight to C7 check uh E5 you
stop this and now Bishop captures on C6
you remove the defender of the E5 Pawn
so Bishop captures with check Queen
captures Queen captures with check and
now finally at the end you connect with
Knight to C7 whatever you play Bishop D7
Knight to C7 check will pick off the
rook and the white uh well should uh
easily win this game so after Queen to
H5 of course Alan did not play that
Anand plays Pawn to A6 which is the
strongest move and the Anand shows that
he knows his theory regarding the even
the the uh you know that scares us of
the sidelines of the Queen's Gambit
accepted so Knight captures on B5 uh and
now Knight to C6 there is a game where
E6 was played but now we have Knight to
C6 and it is now as of move eight
already that we have a completely new
game so okay Bishop captures on C4 we
have Ponte E6 and now Bishop to E3 uh
Anand is down a pawn and uh why is he
down upon white has the strong Center
White already has the Bishops developed
the Knight is accidentally placed the
queen is in the game so what is Anand
gaining uh by by the sacrifice Pawn well
it's it's merely a temporary Pawn
sacrifice because now Anand will win
some Tempe back Knight to F6 attacks the
queen queen doesn't really have all that
many great squares you go to E2 or D1
now aravind goes uh to D1 and now Bishop
to B4 with check now it's time to bring
the Knight back Knight to C3 and now you
regain material Knight captures an E4
also with the threat of just winning
more material and C3 so Knights the E2
adding a Defender and Anand trades
Bishop captures on C3 the B characters
and now Queen back to C7 you don't want
your queen here uh you know white is
ready to put respawn to D5 so Bishop to
F4 continuing to harass the black queen
and queen to D7 now uh we have Castles
by both players and now uh the uh the
opening stage of the game uh is now
finished to what what do the players
have well arvind has the past C Pawn
which could very easily become a pass
deep on if let's see for D5 is played
and Anand has the past a pawn we have
Queen to D3 and now uh Anna no longer
has a past a pawn because the Knight is
hanging and the pawn on A6 will soon be
captured we have Knight to F6 and now
Bishop captures on A6 but pretty much
all of the moves that were played up
until this point where engine moves and
both of them really know how to handle
this position but here Anand plays
Bishop captures on E6 um a more precise
way to tackle this is to throw in this
E5 move but also it's probably something
that you have to know in order to play
it uh because uh how do you how do you
defend this you're obviously not going
to capture with the pawn because then
Bishop captures on A6 will be a big
problem for example Bishop captures on
A6 and what do you play the Queen on D3
is now hanging so you have to capture uh
the queen on D7 and after Queen captures
on the seven Knight captures on D7 or
the the E5 Pawn is hanging and you will
win it back so it's a nice position
tonight I need to sing in black is just
much better here so what you would have
to do after E5 you cannot touch the pawn
you have to play Bishop captures and C8
attack the queen and now okay you will
play Rook cat person C8 and now Bishop
to G5 you will play Knight to D5 and now
D captures on E5 Knight captures on E5
attacks the queen queen to E4 and now
you trade Rook captures on A1 Rook
captures an A1 and now Knight to G6 and
okay white is up upon but it's uh a pawn
that can easily be stopped the Knight is
already there The Rook is already there
the queen will join the action and the
white does not have the c a C4 movie
White had the C4 move uh then it could
be a little bit better because here if
you play Pawn to C4 okay the Knight is
attacked Knight to B6 and there is no
more advancing the pawn now the the pawn
will just be captured here you could go
Rook to C1 defend the pawn uh Pawn to H6
Bishop to E3 and now you can simply play
Knight captures on e4 that's the on C4
that's the point so after Bishop
captures an A6 uh E5 is the it's Vision
2 that you should find but I don't play
Bishop captures on A6 and now you're
gonna see the difference Rook captures
an A6 Rook captures an A6 Queen captures
an A6 and now okay we have Knights to D5
attacks the bishop ended the pawn here
and now Bishop to G3 the C3 Pawn is
nicely defended but there is no good way
for Anand to stop Pawn to C4 uh we have
Queen to C8 offering a queen trade uh
Rook to A1 the queen is nicely defended
Anand trades here we have characters
captures attacks the knight uh Rook to
C8 defends the Knight but now uh he's
not waiting around to see what happens
Pawn to C4 now Anand has to deal with
this we have Knight Dita B4 and now Rook
to A4 also Rook to B6 is a very nice
move just um controlling both Knights
Rook to A4 and now we have Pawn to F6 uh
we have Pawn to F3 and Knight to D3 now
uh we have Pawn to C5 it's a pass Pawn
so of course it should be Advanced uh
Advanced as far as possible and now Pawn
to E5 now and then place it and he wants
the uh mess up white spawn structure in
the center we have rooked A3 attacks the
Knight and now Knight D to B4 uh you
would very much like the capture this
but you can't as Knight captures and C5
would happen so here are in the attacks
the Knight and now knight uh comes the
B4 also this Knight could come uh then
the idea is the same of course if the
the pawn moves or if the pawn captures
an E5 you can always capture on C5 but
this Knight came to B4 and now we simply
have D captures on E5 Knight captures an
E5 Bishop characters eka F characters
and now Rook the C3 so we end the line
by arvind having a rook behind the pass
Pawn which is not ideal we have Knight
to a six Anand goes after the pawn C6
Knight back to B4 and again goes after
the pawn and now Pawn to C7 and the
problem is now Ananda does not have 9 to
the D5 it seems like you attacked the
rook and you're gonna win the C7 Pawn
but not really because there's Rook C5
and now the problem is if you uh if you
capture with the Rook you lose the
Knight and if you capture with the
Knight then look at this of course you
don't go after the pawn you play Knight
to C3 how are you stopping Knight D5
there's no move you can make the king is
too far away if King F7 Knights the B5
or D5 doesn't really matter and now you
will have to give up the exchange and
white is now winning so after King to
see after they spawn to C7 move Anand
realizes that okay we can't play that we
have to bring our King a little bit
closer now the king is in range so you
could play this uh line that we've just
said but now comes at night to G3 we
have Knights the D5 attacking the rook
and pawn and Rook the C5 attacking the
Knight but now Anan just plays King to
E6 and everything is nicely defended uh
Knight to E4 and now what do you play
well Alan plays Pawn to H6 here probably
safest was to just capture the pawn here
and allow add the knights the G5 check
for example Knights the G5 king of five
you're gonna capture uh on D5 with the
Rook probably not going for Rook
captures on C7 is also possible then
maybe you capture on H7 but this seems
safer you just capture that and after
King captures will captures on E5 uh and
still okay you're up a pawn but um
um three against two on the same side of
the board it's a rook end game it's a
draw so H6 was played and now we have
rooked the C6 with check this allows
aravind to bring his Rook over to the
king sites to go after the pawns King E7
and now Rook to G6 putting pressure on
the pawn here and again a passive King
to f8 is the best way to defend this but
Anand goes for Rook captures on C7 which
is still a draw but it allows aravind to
play uh for the win because Rook
captures on G7 and now Anand played King
to f8 the strongest move is King to E6
but even with over two minutes on the
clock Ananda did not spot his mistake he
played King to f8 and now feel free to
pause the video and try to spot the move
that Anand did not find uh while I give
you a second or of course the move that
wins the game for uh chitambaram
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the the
two nasty forks and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Rook
captures on C7 this is an essential move
to start with but it's the next move
that you have to find that really
matters Rook captures on C7 Knight
captures and now congratulations to
everyone who founded Knight to F6 this
is the move that wins the game basically
as uh now you're threatening Knight to
D7 check this Fork will win you the E5
pawn and the only way to defend it if
the Knight cannot defend upon and you
cannot Advance the pawn further to E4
you have to move the king in order to
avoid the fork which of course is what
Anand did but now comes the other
Fortnight to the G4 now Forks the two
pawns and you have to give up one of
them so Anan decided to mess up
aravine's Pawn structure at the price of
a pawn at least something F captures an
E4 and now Pawn to H5 we have knighted
the E5 with check King to F6 and now
Knight back to F3 and now by playing
this little maneuver uh aravind's pawn
and Knight create a wall here against
Anand King so Anand cannot reach the
pawn if he could grab this Pawn then he
could draw but he cannot get closer to
it Knight D6 was played now comes King
to F2 and he was in this position animal
46 that vishwanathan Anand resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here uh chitambaram was under a
minute but uh Anand of course uh knows
that he will have no problems winning
this as he's not up upon he's up two
pawns and for those of you who are maybe
new to chess so we could even show how
um easily white can convert this for
example uh black has to play something
uh we still cannot get anywhere near
here with our King you have to play
something let's say Knight to F4 so if
the king moves at least you're
pressuring the pawn but just H4 and now
once I'm always made you're gonna kick
away the Knight and once the Knight
moves you're gonna kick away the Knight
further win some squares here and
eliminate the H5 Pawn for example Knight
the B4 You're Gonna Go King F4 and if
King F6 you're just gonna play E5 with
check the pawn is nicely defended it
doesn't really matter where you go to uh
if if you go here then the Knight comes
into the game the pawn can be pushed
further and if you go here then you go
after the pawn you pick up the pawn and
uh it's just too much two pawns are too
much to handle there are of course some
positions but not not likely when it's a
night end again maybe when it's a bishop
end game especially if you have like a
double Pawn or something but two pawns
is uh more than enough in most cases one
Pawn is more than enough if you if you
play you know precise moves two points
is just too much uh so yeah very nicely
done by Adam in the eliminating and not
eliminating defeating former world
champion Michiana Island like this and
much like a Vladimir kramnik uh he only
lost one game in this event and it is
this one to chitambaram Armand uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you very much for
suggesting such a lovely game if you
have any other suggestions use hashtag
suggestion and I will go over it it's a
wonderful game so I'm very very happy
that I was able to show it to everyone
so once again hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Andrew Wooley
mocosoft the grizzly chess
festival.org.gg India Moon and in is the
best for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World and also we will be
having a live stream
uh regarding improve I will have the
founder of improve on on the live stream
today if you guys want you can ask some
questions the link is still in the
description below uh already more than
10 000 people have downloaded our app
for improving at chess so if you still
haven't checked it out do do try it uh
first link in the description below so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day